foreign
what's up Ally
hey Dr John it's so awesome to talk to
you yeah it's awesome to talk to you
you're in my neighborhood you should
have just come on down what's up I
actually drove by Ramsey Solutions just
the other day I was like oh it was
Saturday so you weren't there I wasn't
there actually I lived here my wife
kicked me out and so I lived just
kidding she didn't thanks so so what's
up
okay well I'm sorry I'm super nervous
I'm gonna try to be direct but I I like
to talk so um just cut me off whenever I
like to talk too so let's do it let's do
it
okay so I'm struggling I listen to your
show a lot and I I really appreciate all
that you do I try to apply what you say
to my life and and this is just one area
where I'm just struggling with you talk
about you know pictures that we have and
I had this picture of what I thought
that Christmas was going to look like
with a new baby and my family and it
doesn't feel like that's actually the
reality of what my picture was and I'm
kind of grieving that
um and I don't really know how to
process it I don't really know
what the right thing for me to do if I
should lean into family even though it's
really difficult with a baby or if I
should kind of pull out a little bit and
my husband and I kind of do our own
tradition I'm just kind of struggling
what what do you what did you think it
was going to look like and what is
reality
okay
[Music]
well I'm very
overstimulated and I have a big family
and so we've had some family gatherings
with him
um we just recently did Thanksgiving and
it was not at all like I love
Thanksgiving and being with my family
but I spent the entire Thanksgiving like
in another room trying to soothe him
because it was just too much for him
um you know and I guess I imagined
everybody passes the baby around and
it's his first Christmas and I'm just
proud mama in the corner and the reality
because it is that I am in a room by
myself singing 99 bottles of milk on the
wall to this child that just can't deal
and Ally beer beer alley milk is not
going to solve your problems milk is not
going to solve your problems
um hey it's like
it's a bummer too did you get did you
get did you get a bunch of advice for
what you should be doing and oh God yeah
Rando uncles and aunts who know
everything and your parents especially
have any children oh yeah exactly well
and your parents thought this would be
when they show off how good of a job
they did at parenting You by how good
well-behaved your kid is and um so they
had to make up for your utter failures
to control a form month old right what a
mess yeah I know okay so what do you
think is gonna happen in Christmas are
you just picturing a replay of what just
went down at Thanksgiving
yes okay and I don't want to do it
hey let's just feel guilty uh okay
perfect you're right where you should be
because this is yes if you didn't feel
guilty you would probably need to go see
somebody immediately
it something would be malfunctioning and
I hate to use mechanized language but
there would be something wrong
you have to say I mean you you're
exhausted number one your marriage as
good as it can be is still wonky because
it's all messed up and new now right
you're still trying to figure out what
that is it's in Nashville so it's gray
and it's been cold and rainy and then
hot and then rainy again and cold
and then you just went through a holiday
where you spent it bouncing a kid up and
down who just pooped and yelled and ate
on repeat and so you missed it all
and then you've had this picture if it's
gonna be like this like this like
and then your body says hey I'm out
let's don't do that
and I think this might be right for you
in the season and you're gonna feel
super guilty because you want to be a
the kid that makes Mom and Dad happy
you've probably been a peacemaker for a
lot of your life you want to bring your
kid around and not miss Christmas and
yada yada you want all these things but
there's a reality to it or maybe there's
a middle ground that's going to be maybe
we're gonna lean into it for a little
bit but not all the way so I I I really
respect the fact that you're listening
to your body right now and you're saying
out loud I don't want this I don't want
to experience again what I just went
through good for you that's that's huge
and that you're feeling guilty yes
you're right where you should be so
where does your family live where are
they doing Christmas
oh they're they're close most of them
live in either Murfreesboro or
Shelbyville and Christmas is going to be
at Shelby in Shelbyville okay so for
those of you listening it's it's within
an hour right or an hour hour and a half
it's around
um is there a possibility that you say
we're gonna go for three hours and head
out
yeah I guess I'm thinking okay an hour
drive there and then three hours of
there's a room with a upset child for
maybe 15 minutes of FaceTime with
everybody and then an hour back I guess
I'm just kind of already I don't want to
say resenting but I think I'm already
resenting that
are you resenting that or are you
resenting the fact that you're going to
go all the way out there and your baby's
not going to cooperate
yes that's a different proposition
because then you're not resenting them
you're just resist you're just I don't
even think you're at resentment now
resentment is when you hope somebody
else's life isn't going well I don't
think I think you're just frustrated and
sad and mad and frustrated and sad and
mad and frustrated on Loop and that's
super okay because life with a four
month old is super frustrating I
remember thinking my four-year-old was
gonna be like we're gonna be playing
Spades we've been playing cards like
playing Texas Hold'em and it was just
like a lump that crapped all the time
and I I just remember being frustrated
so much more than I thought I was going
to be and then I had to say the
obligatory oh it's the best thing ever
it was hard and then I didn't know who
my wife was oh that was hard
um I think you'll regret not going for a
few minutes now if you were telling me
you're gonna travel four hours or six
hours or eight hours I think it would be
super fair to say hey this year just not
a good year
I think we've got a newborn we're still
figuring things out
um this won't be a good year we'll
FaceTime everybody and we'll you know
we'll do all that but we're I'm
exhausted and this isn't a good year
being within an hour I think long term
um like a six hour half day
yes is gonna be a pain but I think that
um you'll regret not doing that that's
just my that's just my opinion there's a
little bit more than that there's
actually like three or four family
gatherings over the span of Christmas
Eve and Christmas let's reframe that
let's reframe
different groups of your family are
going to get together for multiple times
you're not yes
and that's I guess where I'm at is the
group is getting together and I feel
like that's the time that's
I don't know because I feel like that's
going to be the most not
in tune with my family that I'm gonna be
I feel like the smaller groups with my
parents and then my mom and my little
sister separately and then my
grandparents those are those I'm looking
forward to because
I feel like there's less people there's
less stimuli and you can go to that
there's more understanding then go to
those
here's the beautiful thing about the
moment you're in you get to choose
I just don't want to make the wrong
choice or have people feel like because
I opted out of one family gathering one
time that they're gonna opt out
in the future you can't control well you
might opt out in the future
you can't control how other adults
respond to your boundaries
you can't you can't control how other
adults respond to what you need in a
particular season
and right now you've got a four month
old who doesn't do well in big groups
and you've got people without kids who
love giving information about what you
should be doing to raise this kid
and it's not a good environment so cool
we're gonna take a year
I think in 20 years you're going to wish
you had that photo but you're also going
to have multiple opportunities for small
group get-togethers like you just
mentioned and maybe those are going to
be better situated and since you're
close you can make that call
um that sounds great
here's the here's the Neta here
I don't think there's a wrong
there's only a wrong if you allow it to
be wrong in 10 years you might really
wish
I wish I just gone
but then you can remember back and say
yeah it wasn't going to happen that year
I'm all good I made the best decision
for me at the time
yeah does that make sense
it does and this is the worst part of
having kids it's the worst it's the
worst it's just it's sad because like
I I don't blame my kid because he's a
baby he's a baby I just didn't imagine
it was going to be like this but you're
blaming yourself
don't do that
yeah don't blame you
you're a new mom
yeah and you're practicing this and
missing the big shindig is is gonna
cause all oh my gosh great guys I'm
gonna see you like in two days
yeah it's not gonna happen on this one
what's your husband think
he pretty much 100 agrees with you he's
very well we're just going to tell him
we're not coming and I'm like no we have
to fight no actually you you married a
hero I Need a Hero
you married him you married
the best he hey he's he sounds like he's
the best just off this one thing
um yeah here's what I want you to do a
couple of things I want you to be very
specific about here's what I wanted
okay and if you're a real gangster
you'll you'll take half an hour when
your baby's asleep and you're not dozing
off and you'll write this down here's
what I wanted
and I want you to write it down be very
very specific and then I want you to
write down why you wanted it this way
did you want to do it because you wanted
to show off baby because you wanted
pictures for 20 years from now because
you wanted to prove to everybody see I
made it or I did like be very specific
why did you actually care about this
because this is just the way this is
supposed to be my mom wanted me there
like be very specific about it and then
be super clear about what is
yeah what is right with no judgments
just this is the reality we just did
Thanksgiving baby gets overstimulated we
have a lot of loud wild family it's just
not going to be a good situation for any
of us it took four days to get baby
resettled again and back in routine it's
just not a fight I want to have during
the holidays not our first Christmas
together
with our new family that that's starting
off
and I want you to be very clear on this
one thing I'm going to put in front of
you you get to decide
to choose Joy or misery moving forward
you don't think that there's any like
maybe this is irrational because your
little nephew didn't come to Christmas
we don't have as close of a connection
with him as we could ABS I mean that's
b-a-n-n-a-s for four months for a four
month old here's here's what the
greatest gift you can give to a four
month old
is a mom who's got peace
three
and baby is going to take a lot of cues
from Mom
not all but a lot
so a mom who's not stressed
will generally speaking directionally
speaking have a baby who's less stressed
a mom who is at peace who is having Joy
will have a baby who's nah not always
there's colicky babies and I was
peaceful in my baby ah well
we could probably go down a rabbit hole
in that one but
I would try to create
a non-anxious Christmas let's try that
we're going to create a non-anxious
Christmas one where you take care of
your body
um you're gonna have movement you're
gonna sleep when you can which I know is
a disaster with a four month old you're
gonna eat you're gonna enjoy meals but
you're not gonna go down like
would do it to your body what I did to
mine this past week on a trip to Texas I
ate myself
blind and
um you're gonna take care of your body
you're gonna make sure you stay
connected with your husband you're gonna
have boundaries you're gonna do the next
right thing and if you wake up that
morning and your baby's in a great mood
you think I think we can pull this off
take your baby just show up don't be so
surprised and if you wake up that
morning and you're like not happening
don't go just don't go
just don't go and if you feel sad
feel sad feel sad it's okay to feel sad
and then look for beauty
look for things that make you laugh talk
through a plan with your husband about
what here's what I need you to do when I
start getting sad
my guess is if you choose to build a
non-anxious Christmas you can figure out
the path that way the path to a
non-anxious Christmas and that is going
to create for a great Christmas Memories
and a really really happy baby